Hustling 24/7 on
the Instagram DM.
It is the 2017 opportunity.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Time Is Ticking"
by Marc Aliotta)
DRock and I are
walking to do a haircut talk.
Barbershop talk.
- Barbershop.
- [DRock] Gary, how
often do you get a haircut?
- I try to do it
every 2 to 3 weeks.
'Cause I like keeping
it short on the sides.
Go ahead.
But Manny's the best.
Whenever Manny's around.
Alright, so here
getting my haircut with Manny.
Manny, how long you
been cutting my hair now?
Two years you think?
Three?
- Almost two years.
- [Gary] Two.
You know, I used to go to
another place where Manny worked
and had a bunch of different
guys that would cut my hair but
Manny cut it one time.
I liked it extra short,
it was just perfect.
So that's what
I've been going with.
So, me and Manny shoot the shit.
Last couple times I've
been quiet at the haircut.
I just been so focused.
But in the
never-ending quest to
pump out seven days a week,
gonna hack so I think,
you know, barbershop talk.
So last, DRock, that was pretty
good how we did the Sunday week
ahead look, right?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- So let's do that.
- [DRock] It was great.
- Another thing
I want to talk about.
I want to edit the #AskGaryVee
show where I told the guy
who was building
small business websites,
how to go into search.
How to search the
hashtags, how to go to DM.
A lot of people like to talk
about how it's going down in the
DM on Instagram and I
know that's for hooking up and
Netflix and chill and all that
but it's also going down for
business development.
And so I'm gonna talk
about, thank you so much.
- [DRock] It's my new email.
- It's your new email.
To me, it's where people could
be doing so much business damage
and I'll talk about that in
one second while I give you the
quick review of the week ahead.
So tomorrow, big MLK day.
I'm going to the Knicks game,
taking one of the kids and then
I've got a meeting with Kelly.
Kelly McCarthy who was my right
hand along with AJ in building
VaynerMedia in the early days.
Now killing it at Nike and then
just some family stuff and some
phone calls with
Brandon from Wine Library.
Tuesday, early
morning basketball, 6 A.M.
Meeting with a
former client at 8:30.
Another client meeting at 9.
Another client meeting at 10:30.
Then a live
webinar for something.
Then a couple internal
meetings for nonprofit stuff.
Then, is this Russ's manager?
A little face time
with Amar, Russ's manager.
- [DRock] Amar will be coming
in and Russ is gonna be on--
- Oh yeah?
That's awesome.
If you haven't
heard Russ's music,
you've been missing out.
Then my dad and
Brandon coming by,
that's huge.
Another client,
another client, VaynerSports,
internal, internal,
internal, internal.
Client, internal.
Client, former employee,
and then (laughs)
in studio with 21 Savage.
You heard it here first.
It's a huge Atlanta hip hop day.
21 Savage and Russ.
And I go, I got a speaking
engagement on Wednesday morning,
first thing in the morning.
Then, I've got a client meeting,
then an all day thing at Pepsi.
Then couple of internal things.
Randi Zuckerberg, one of
my dear friends stopping by.
Football player stopping by.
Internal, internal, Skippa
Tha Flippa if you don't know.
Man, it's so hip
hopped out lately.
Client, client, then
flying to London at night.
London Thursday
morning, London, workout,
then some internal client stuff.
Client in Maidenhead, UK.
Client, client, client, client.
And then wake up
Friday morning in London,
fly back to New York, land.
Work on the book and then dinner
with Ryan Harwood and his lovely
wife to celebrate
the PureWow deal.
That is the week ahead.
80% clients, 20% hip hop.
(DRock laughs)
Alright, now let's
bring you some value here.
I'm obsessed with this.
DRock, maybe we can get
some, maybe we can do this.
Get in here.
Let's say you want to
sell websites to plumbers.
So 136,000.
And you go and see, you
click, and you see who this is.
This is a custom design firm.
B2B commercial in Toronto.
148,000 followers.
This is what they post.
Let's say you want to build
business websites for small
businesses or you want
to do social media for small
businesses, you
go right up here.
You hit send message.
You getting this DRock?
- [DRock] Yep.
- [Gary] Very good.
Send message.
And then here is the key.
The key here is to
jab, jab, jab, right hook.
Love what you're doing.
Would love to be able
to bring you some value.
Are you doing
anything around marketing?
Let me know, have a great day.
XOXO. Heart.
Send.
Here's the key, what
I just did, go ahead Manny.
What I just did is something
that I've been doing for years.
Back in 2006 and '07 Twitter
I would do that except I would
reply publicly 'cause it
was a different platform.
Different cadences, different
acceptable social norms.
The thing that blows me away is
how many of you are so hungry,
how many of you are asking for
how do you do things and the
reality is it's very simple.
It's hand to hand combat.
It's business development.
It's handing out
virtual business cards.
But the reality is so many of
you don't want to do it 'cause
it's hard.
What I just did,
if you're hungry,
if you want to win
you have to do for five,
six, seven,
eight, nine hours a day.
Let's show another one, DRock.
Okay, the fitness hashtag.
You know only 168 million.
Breaks it into top
posts and most recent.
So you go to a top post.
Manny's paying attention, wants
to get some barber clients.
Alright so here's Zap, right?
I click him.
He's got 546,000 people, right?
I see he's a musician and
he's a band and he's in Cairo.
Let's just say
for whatever reason,
I want to do product placement
and I have a new shake or
energy drink or hoodies or for
example this is what everybody
should be doing with me if they
want me to wear their sneakers
or their beanies, right?
I wear beanies, I wear hoodies,
I wear sneakers.
I would hit this person up,
I would hit them up and say,
"Zap, love what you do,
"would love to connect. Right?
Or would love to send
you my favorite wines,
if I was in the wine business.
Or would love to make
three to four videos
for your Instagram
account on me.
Or would love to send
your friends some beef jerky.
Or and that's the key.
It's or and I would
love to give you.
What I get all day is
Gary, can you give me a
shout out on my account?
Gary, can you make me famous?
Gary, can you do this?
Gary, can you do that?
I've got the leverage, not you.
If you're asking, you
don't have the leverage.
So anytime I'm
hitting somebody up,
regardless if I'm
bigger or smaller than them,
I'm asking.
So I'm trying to
give them love. Right?
That's the key.
People don't give love.
When we're hitting
up and coming artists,
both hip hop and what have you,
we're trying to give them love.
Hey, we'd love to
give you exposure.
Would you like to
give us the opportunity?
Everybody's
trying to, last night,
I hit up a couple of people
that follow me that are really,
really big and
they both replied to me.
Check this out, DRock.
We're not gonna show this.
This is more that
I want your crazy reaction.
(DRock laughs)
Look at this.
I'll show you in a second.
This is insane. Ready?
Look at this.
- [DRock] That's crazy.
- Got another one too.
- [DRock] Amazing.
- Isn't that the craziest thing?
- [DRock] That is crazy.
- Where is it?
I hope I didn't delete this one.
I might of.
Let me see.
Nope, I didn't.
- [DRock] That's so nuts.
- The key is providing
other people more value.
I just don't
see people doing it.
It blows me away
and it is absolutely,
I want the full, and it is
absolutely going
down on Instagram DM.
The key is do
you know how to jab,
jab, jab, right hook
on Instagram DM.
Search hashtags,
click them, look at the account.
Then see how you
can bring them value.
DM them.
Go in soft, bring value,
rinse and repeat.
Two, three, four,
five thousand times.
One of the great
accomplishments in the last
three, four months
in my community is the
2017 Flip Challenge. Right?
People are making
actual money on eBay.
They couldn't believe they could
sell stuff laying
around their house.
They're now using Craigslist and
Let's Go and Etsy and they're
learning and I'm
watching people learn oh,
I didn't make money here.
I'm watching you guys learn.
You're getting better.
People making real flips.
Business development, it's one
of the pillars of my success.
The reason I'm good at business
development is I try to bring
more value to the
other person first.
It's always gonna
be the same thing.
50 years of content,
it's gonna say the same thing.
Provide the other
person more value. Right?
More value than they give you.
If somebody has a million
followers and you want them to
give a shout out to
your work, your stuff,
you need to overwhelm
them with value first.
For example, more example
time, I want this to be a heavy
example time.
Here we go.
So, let's say you do,
let's say you like hip hop.
And let's say you love
Chance The Rapper, right?
So you go to Chance The Rapper.
The guy's got
2.9 million followers.
He's getting hit up
a million times a day.
When you send
him a thing, Chance,
I make videos.
I'll make you the
best Instagram videos
for free for an entire year.
Your account will
go to 7 million.
Let alone 2.9.
I won't bother you,
I'll just work.
I'll need access
at times but
you control that.
Let me know,
look at my work on my Insta.
Much love.
Over and over and over.
Got to make sure your
Instagram account is on point
if you got that.
If him or one of his boys
actually look at it or somebody
who's controlling the account
they need to see those
videos and think they're fire.
That's the key.
But you go over and over.
Manny should do this.
15 times a day, 20 times a day.
Let me show you
how Manny should do it.
So the thing Manny
should do is go Upper East Side.
Right, so he's going by location
and so he sees top posts, right?
So he sees this well
this looks like an account.
I guess this is a blogger.
Looks like she's just visiting
and keep looking, right?
Keep looking at most recent.
This guy looks
like he took a picture.
Good took a selfie
in the Upper East Side.
Comes here he's
got 41,000 followers.
He looks at the model
so Manny should go here,
send message.
Hey G,
thrilled to give you
five free haircuts
over the next
six months.
Let me know if
you're interested.
This is what
Manny should do here.
Manny sits here on Tuesday from
2:30 to 3:30 while he is waiting
for a client and he sits on his
fucking ass and instead what he
should be doing should be
going to Instagram searching
the Upper East Side and
DM'ing people 20, 30,
40 times a day
offering free haircuts
'cause he just
started his business.
He needs the exposure.
He shouldn't
even ask that model,
he has 46,000 followers,
he shouldn't
even say in the first
contact hey I'll
give you free haircut,
you give me a shout out because
then that's person knows that
he's just doing doing for that.
It's jab, jab, jab
without the right hook.
He should just say, "Hey,
I like your Instagram account.
"I just opened my barbershop.
"I'd love to give you six free
haircuts or two," or whatever or
how busy Manny is right
now, "over next three months."
Guy comes even if he never asks,
I've known Manny for two years.
He's never asked me.
Then I took the
picture on Snapchat.
You build a relationship.
When doing the right thing,
you're always
doing the right thing.
But to me,
I think about it like sawdust.
If you've got downtime,
why not business develop?
The fact you can business
develop in this thing now is
insane and if you offer
something in return 3 out of 30
people will take you up on it.
He may not but the next person
might and then you business
develop and then
you business develop
and things start happening.
Hustling 24/7 on
the Instagram DM,
it is the 2017 opportunity.
(rap music)
You hear my
new theme song?
This is my new theme
song when I post DailyVee.
- [DRock] What is it?
- You'll see.
("pick up the phone"
by Young Thug)
See what it is?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- I love this song.
While we're here, since
these episodes are short.
Big shout out, I'm looking
for 5 to 7 video interns.
People that can edit,
what would we really need?
People that
really know my stuff.
What are they called?
- [DRock] They're
called predators.
- Predators.
- [DRock] Filmers.
- Filmers.
- [DRock] Producers and editors.
- Producers and editors.
Predators.
Alright, I'm looking for five
up-and-coming predators
who want to be interns.
Who want to put in
their year's due for a year,
siphon off my attention.
We give you shout outs and
tagging you in the work that you
do and then either do what the
majority of the crew is doing
which is triple down and want to
run with me for a while or use
the exposure to
do your own thing.
Looking for high quality peeps,
DRock's gonna be
the judge and the jury.
You got to be really strong
but I'm looking for five ASAP.
Boy, girl, black,
white, red, green,
orange, Pakistan,
Sri Lanka, New Jersey.
I don't give a
shit if you've got it.
Everything but Patriot fans.
(DRock laughs)
Other than that if you got it,
we want to see
the work, 24/7 hustle.
Minimum a year.
No going back to school, this
is what you gotta do but we're
looking for you and here's DRock
or here's the email they came up
with DRock, Tyler, maybe a
couple others will look at it.
I don't know what
you guys are gonna do.
But here it is.
It's flashing and can't
wait for you to join the team.
And if you can't do that, one
of the things we're trying to do
now is #FanVee.
#FanVee people
creating compilation videos
around my content.
The kind of stuff we put out
so that I can put it out on
Instagram, YouTube, Facebook,
Twitter videos under a minute
are especially great 'cause
I'm looking for
Instagram video content.
And also stuff that
we haven't talked about.
So people going back in the
archives and finding quotes or
things, using the #AskGaryVee
search engine I think would be
really smart around your concept
or strategy and I would even
make an original one or two
second video for you if you
needed to add to it and you
can just email me on that that
you're working on that
project and what you need.
So, #FanVee get on board.
Yes, sir?
Done?
(DRock laughs)
Did we do eyebrows?
- Yeah.
- You did?
We're finished?
- Yes.
- It's all over.
We're done.
Alright. Thank you.
Alright my friend,
great to see you.
- Thank you.
- Love you.
You gonna use the Instagram DM?
Can literally search
the Upper East Side.
- [Manny] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] You can
literally see everybody
who's posting in the area.
- [Manny] Yeah.
- [Gary] Right.
- [Manny] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] So again,
you know this person
ate here so you click
this person and you
can literally go up here,
send them a message, say,
"I like your Instagram account.
"If you like a
free haircut come by."
What's great about that is these
are individuals who already like
to share their lives.
So if they come, they'll give
a shout out and it creates,
you know, you
live on word of mouth.
- [Manny] Yeah.
- What's your business?
It's word of mouth.
This is word of
mouth on steroids.
Learn.
You need it,
especially right now as
you're building a new business.
Every minute counts.
You know?
Love you.
(rap music)
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [DRock] That
was a great episode.
- [Gary] I think so too.
(Gary and DRock laugh)
I think your doubt
motivated me. (DRock laughs)
We can tie in the
content to what we did a year
ago 'cause a year ago
recalls I think are insane.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Like once we start building a
library or searching this day on
#AskGaryVee two years ago.
There's never been a day
where I've had to activate.
It's always on.
And I don't mean
always on buzzword marketing,
it's that I love what I do so
much that there is no friction
to turn it on even when I am
landing at 2 o'clock in the
morning from a flight that's
delayed like the other night and
then going directly in to it at
6:30 in the morning because the
fire is so deep inside.
You love it so much.
You know, you don't
need that jumpstart.
Guys, have a great weekend.
See you tomorrow.
Happy Martin Luther King's day.
Went to Martin Luther King
Elementary School
in Edison, New Jersey.
Little fun fact.
I was the
President in fifth grade.
(rap music)